good morning
[Music]
[Music]
earth down
i want to tell you my secret now
okay
i see
not funny people
like on your facebook timeline
on your instagram
snapchat
you see him in real life
like on tv
not funny people like jimmy kimmel
samantha bee
on cable television
like the real funny people
they don't make me laugh
they only see their point of view
they don't know they're not funny
how often do you see them
every night
they're
everywhere you won't tell anyone my
secret right
no
will you stay
and tell me some jokes
i can't
we're about to tape.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
what are you sipping at
that's my question oh man it's been a
wonderful uh we've been uh gone here
since uh wednesday happy belated
thanksgiving yeah
hey i call it uh uh the wee one day
yes yeah
sorry not sorry day no sorry not sorry
no you know people were saying this that
you know there were some protest people
saying we want our land back i go oh
okay which one mm-hmm which tribe will
give it back to the mohawks you require
the algonquin before them go back to the
hurons
which one oh all of it okay i'm sure you
already spent those beaver pelts yes
okay give us our stuff back that we gave
you in exchange for the land our winters
are robust i can't and i get very little
service here on my 414 pro so
uh we have a lot to get to today we just
found that jack dorsey will be stepping
down yeah
from the twitter so
let me know
uh we have some info for you on that
that's why we're a little bit late uh
also what i will be talking about today
and we were going to talk about this
before the cal written house stream kind
of
took over last week
is the idea that i do think we're closer
to either a civil war or a breakup or
secession than we've ever been at some
at any point in my lifetime i think
we'll see it in our lifetime joe lewis
i'm i'm starting the show i mean
we're crying out loud
yeah he just wants a taste um
and the funny thing is i'll show you
some stats i'll show you some clips from
people so ted cruz to sarah silverman to
you have congressional uh
you know
men and women z's yeah uh on both the
left and the right who are talking about
breaking up the united states what does
that look like and who remains the
united states versus who becomes america
number two working country title yeah
and i think you can guess where i line
up but i i think it's important to talk
about because i will tell you this look
i think we're at a point where it is
undeniable that the left liberals in the
united states
don't
don't like they hate america there you
cannot be patriotic and be a current
progressive i don't think it's possible
i think it used to be i think jfk loved
america i think even peanut farmer
himself carter to some degree loved
america
we're at a point now where they are
diametrically opposed patriotism is seen
as white nationalism it's seen as white
supremacy what even if you're a black
guy running for governor of california
so i don't know what to do anymore up is
down down is up and i don't know what
i'm going to do without jack dorsey
before we get to all of that cheryl day
how are you i am well how are you sir
okay a little good thanksgiving a very
good thanksgiving you eat a lot of food
i gained five pounds on 48 hours nice
really yes how is that even possible
it's possible when it's turkey season
bro
it wasn't just turkey apparently he had
a second night of food i had a second
night of prime rib oh we made a prime
rib that's awesome most people that's a
good plan understand their mistake in
the day after eat lighter no no i didn't
i go hard steered into it
full tilt good for the heart that's a
good thing but for the hard quarter
black speaking start what's going on
black garrett at risk of myocarditis but
hopefully i'm in a turkey coma right now
i still can't i'm not sluggish oh that's
that tryptophan it is it is that amino
acid tryptophan you got to be careful
with that tryptophan
and uh he will be appearing at uh the
comedy cove in springfield new jersey
this weekend dave landau how are you sir
ahoy good you have good thanksgiving so
much blood
really so if i eat your turkey
you eat my turkey you know it's great
you're just the afterbirth lando
dave did detroit win this week at the
line yeah they did what no they didn't i
was texting with gerald i was they were
up by one i was like just hang on
we're gonna see
literally one second left on the clock i
was like here we go
we're now winner
well
sorry detroit i know we have a lot of
detroiters who watch the show but um
yeah well they're not you dug your own
grave and by the way they know what the
name of one of your neighborhoods is
grave ah yes that's just strength that's
like as shocking as it turning into
night you're like oh this never happens
right
more shocks when it turns into day
because smog uh hey look we're going to
be talking about a lot but
we have no idea what's going to happen
with youtube so the best way for you to
watch this show is tune in monday
through thursday live 10 a.m eastern
today we start a little bit late we
start at 10 30 eastern because of jack
dorsey news which we have here you can
watch here you can watch on rumble and
you can watch of course on mug club
where we will be reading a whole
buzzfeed article
today we are about plus size people and
how it affected the medical treatment
they received look forward to that some
of these are just hysterical
i'm not even joking one of them involves
a doctor prescribing washing yourself
with a rag on a stick
like bart simpson yes yes and and then
and then someone said this is horrible
the bet the best course of action is to
complain about this
at buzzfeed
as one does
never do this segment on youtube that's
one point all right before we uh move on
we uh have to start with this uh the
left on tick tock they're embracing the
holiday season with uh you know you
would think yuletide yeah yeah you'd
think maybe a little bit of a little bit
of holly a little bit of a missile
[Music]
my ears are bleeding
yeah well so will her
[Music]
heart i'll cry
someone get on a plane to south africa
can we do that yeah
why is lip-syncing a talent all of a
sudden no she's not lip-syncing
no that's her really yeah that's all her
i mean i believe you yes
it's something that we buy uh well i
don't even know what they mean
nice going through life as a whole
now it's the booster
so what does she mean to she is she
asking for the boosters i'm not sure
have you noticed that that's also what
fauci's been saying now the fact the
best course of action is the vaccine and
the booster and they just move on like
we all wait
stop that part what the part about the
vaccine no what else did the part about
i am the science no what was the no you
know what you're doing i don't know what
the booster is a thing and that's what
i'm talking about the vaccine you said
booster
i like your car seat i take all my
medical advice from a [ __ ] hose on
instagram yes i've always said that why
have doctors when i have instagram yep
or uh or of course a tick tock yes
because you can be spotted i'm sorry i
forget what's what now everything's
terrible everything is out i don't have
a tick tock account do you not no well
the good thing is the chai comes can't
spy on you uh and you can follow us by
the way all of us on instagram you can
uh you know all of these places i don't
know if i'm still on tick tock hey
am i still on tech talk or if i've been
banned you're still on tick tock right
yeah we're still interested so we
created a new account right after i was
banned is that the thing yeah
there's a girl who lip syncs our entire
show yeah
put some great numbers
good for her
uh speaking of uh girls uh uh of of of
of
of
no value
yes billy eilish begged her followers to
refrain from eating turkey this
thanksgiving uh with this here we have
this instagram post
of her cradling a turkey
do you have this there tokeno and it's
overlay a he's he's trying is he trying
there it is cradling a turkey
look at that right before he gotcha is
that a mask she wrote turkeys are some
of the most gentle creatures in the
world yeah if you if you pose with one
that's been sedated yeah
yeah i have a video of them surrounding
my car in minnesota yeah not even yeah
turkeys are pricks
turkeys are incredible
yeah they're like canadian geese they're
not cool we should have let those go
there's a reason why we have to harden
them yeah i don't even know why we still
have them they're drier than chicken
larger and meaner
let's just keep the dumb ones who taste
more delicious
and this year when they part in the
turkey kamala's still headed killed no
come on course well the clintons did
well right proxy it was fine hanging out
they're gonna break they're gonna bring
this turkey up in the jalen maxwell
trial and uh do you mean to say that you
were in that shower
how old were you
let the record show that the defendant
said 14 years old
that's prime picking age for a trip i'm
picking an age for a turkey
and prince charles was your attacker she
said 46 million of them are killed every
thanksgiving well that sounds like we
could do better yeah i know it's hard to
change traditions but just keep it in
mind well we did and here's the thing of
course with the activism uh from the
left all of it um
she just this is the look i get it if
you wanna help a turkey yeah just like
we talked about george floyd we talk
about jacob blake talk about joseph
rosenbaum or jojo as mark ruffalo yes
she just so happened to pick a turkey
with a rap sheet a mile long
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hands up don't cluck
that's the same turkey that's turning my
car is it yes yeah i recognize him
anywhere oh my gosh you get a speed ball
on that turkey there's no no telling
what he can do no
i've never been attacked by turkeys
before like in like on the ground not
like in the wild but like actually oh
yeah like if in northern michigan they
have if you they will i mean i literally
took my nine millimeter at my conce i'm
like this is the most ridiculous thing
in the world i'm aiming my walther at a
turkey
this isn't a hunting firearm yeah
i did aimed an even bigger walther right
back at him
what you got feeling froggy
pcp that's not like tryptophan no it's
not like triple fan at all they will
collapse yeah if you like i was at a
friend's house and they would he's like
oh yeah just don't turn your back
you turn your back they chase after you
you have to like actually be aggressive
towards them to get them they're like
the ghosts in super mario world yes and
that shows malice of forethought are you
going to turkey's eye shut parties
for some reason he had like three
turkeys on his property and i'm like
this is ridiculous these things are
gonna come after me we have a lot to ask
you guys but you can comment below have
any of you been attacked by turkeys yeah
it's just us i've been attacked by
canadian geese many many many times so
they're all over belle isle oh yeah
they're all over in michigan just trying
to just trying to barbecue don't you get
out of here yeah i don't know otherwise
you know what
goose could be on the menu and the
christmas goose mother the goose so
that's detroit
do you know i have astigmatism you look
fuzzy who date oh yeah dave i'm fuzzy he
is a little fuzzy he's a little fuzzy he
had a busy thanksgiving
[Laughter]
i thought it was just my ivory people
who are listening on audio right now
it's dave's camera there we go now we
can see those pearly whites beautiful
absolutely beautiful thank you okay uh
just coming in right now jack dorsey and
i you know what i want to hear from you
guys comment below hey no look hey joe
lewis this is the problem is you can get
oh i got a movement now look around
place place get over there play sports
no stop that place right here all right
you know what guys i'm sorry can someone
come in here and grab joe lewis today i
think he just maybe he hasn't been for a
walk or something this morning he sorry
guys this show's a disaster
it's not he just wants to get himself if
turkey if everyone is seated it's fine
the second anyone here gets up he thinks
he's about to be pet and then he moves
over to you and he doesn't let you go
well he's not wrong yeah there's a lot
of it's my time someone give him the
give him the b helmet
you mean the sand fly yeah give him the
sand fly helmet please
the fouchy edition this won't bring back
your [ __ ] honey
[Laughter]
[Music]
not the same not again
so jack dorsey and you guys can comment
on this why do you think jack dorsey is
stepping down we don't have all of the
details now it's just breaking right now
this is breaking right now from cnbc
uh jack dorsey is expected to step down
as ceo yeah now it's it's not known
exactly why but keep in mind uh
stakeholders they did try and force him
out
last year yeah over incredibly slow
growth and keep in mind he was also uh
in i don't know if he was ceo before but
then left and then was back and they've
still been trying to force him out
this uh
this morning i think they've stopped
trading is that what's been going on
yeah they halted trading on the stock
after this is funny oh they're like ah
we're kicking jack dorsey out oh thank
god stock jumps jumped 11 yeah
might not be around forever and you just
watch it go down like ed rooney's
computer like oh yeah we might get rid
of jack dorsey and i was like oh happy
day yeah scott goes up i mean you're
getting rid of the homeless guy from san
francisco yeah you know with that long
run you know what you know what stock
though did go uh down was uh uh beard
birds ah yes not as popular not as much
of a trend make sense well you know i've
lost tons of money oh come on you had to
bring that back i wasn't expecting that
oh geez well you know he's also he's the
ceo of square the payment processing
company their stock is tanking now
because he'll be able to focus full-time
on them oh yes
and because i'm
and i'm just hearing of them now yeah
well no they've been around for what
where have you been get your head out
i've been over at venmo buddy yeah next
thing where the kids have joint custody
of the kids and they kill themselves
yeah
i'm just saying anything he touches he's
like charlie brown oh anything i touch
turns to ruins he hasn't done well for
anything and this is something that i've
talked about in the past
people often say to profit motive now
you can say that with right now and it's
very dangerous that our film industry is
catering to china right whereas the
chinese government is creating
anti-american propaganda videos
and
with
these people right now who work with
social media what's really dangerous is
they are catering to international
interests and they're not actually
taking into account the
country that allowed them to become
twitter in the first place or facebook
and google and so it's a real problem
where these platforms aren't actually to
aren't actually able to fulfill the
purpose they were designed
to fill yeah so it genuinely is a
problem right now and jack dorsey has
done incredibly poorly um we don't know
exactly what let me give you kind of a
few uh of of the the quick hits of jack
dorsey uh he remembered this he was
grilled by ted cruz yeah twitter decided
to and their stock didn't do very well
when this happened this is the one of
the values of seeing a publicly traded
company um they banned the hunter biden
laptop story we know now statistically
there were polls where americans said if
they knew about that story it would have
changed their vote enough americans
would have changed their vote even
assuming safest most secure election of
course yes it still would have swung the
election for donald trump had facebook
twitter google not decided to ban the
hunter biden laptop story here's jack
dorsey being grilled by senator ted cruz
let me ask you was twitter
being a publisher
when it censored the new york post
no we have very clear policies on
um
the conduct we enable in the platform
and if there's a violation uh we take an
enforcement action and people choose
to commit to those policies and into
those terms of service
except your policies are applied in a
partisan and selective manner you claim
it was hacked materials and yet you
didn't block the distribution of the new
york times story that alleged to talk
about president trump's tax returns even
though a federal statute makes it a
crime to distribute someone's tax
returns without their consent you didn't
block any of that discussion did you
whoops nazi policy was focused on
distribution of the actual hack
materials um oh no
the definition of is is
someone give that man some more
ayahuasca he needs clarity he does yeah
he looks like a serial killer in alaska
yes that's exactly
his name 30 days of dorsey
he just needs to we need to know his
middle name yeah like that guy ex
machina he's like oh no that makes sense
and uh
going on the same in the same vein when
tim poole uh raised the issue of free
speech dorsey yet again and this is
pivotal why because the whole idea of it
was a digital town square that's how
twitter was actually pitched yeah
digital town square right square the
idea is also designed to sort of tie
into that to check into places
physically originally
square was designed to be sort of
symbiotic with twitter and like look i
just checked in at whatever mario's
pizza oh okay i'll go there until they
found out that you know it just led to
uh
recorded amounts of rape oh jeez yeah oh
that's terrible rape murder doxxing
they're like ah maybe we shouldn't do
this so much so uh own it down the
purpose of it was supposed to be okay
bypass mainstream media bypass the
gatekeepers that's why twitter developed
speak directly with your fans that's the
value that twitter would bring that's
the currency so when you look at the
series of answers from jack dorsey where
he's unable to articulate
unable to articulate his point of view
on the sole value the currency that
twitter provides that's when you see the
stock take a nosedive not to mention the
inconsistency so tim paul brought up the
idea of free speech here's jack dorsey
articulating his thoughts in a crystal
clear manner in terms of
what we're trying to drive is
opportunity for every single person to
be able to
speak freely on the platform and that's
that's absolutely not true
you you would know a lot of heights
allow hate speech so free speech is not
on your platform i i i said
speak enable everyone
create the opportunity for everyone to
speak on our service unless they've all
right it's hate speech right and then in
part of that the recognition that we're
taking action on is that when some
people encounter particular conduct
that we
see them wanting to remove themselves
from the platform completely which goes
against that principle of enabling
everyone to speak or giving the
opportunity to speak wrong so the rules
are focused on
the the opportunities presented
and we have particular outcomes to make
sure that those opportunities are as
solid as possible okay so this is a
problem that you see and i'm gonna go
next to the inconsistency about not
banning global leaders do you see what
he just said there do you see what there
was a very clear question by tim poole
and i do want to hear from you guys if
you you see how perverse this is and you
see this a lot anyone who has uh
if you're married you see this a lot
where sometimes let's say you're having
an argument and then all of a sudden it
becomes about your reaction to something
that was said that was maybe out of line
or hurtful right and then you react and
you get mad and it becomes you've
reacted this way in this case he says we
support free speech okay but then some
people on the platform are saying hey i
don't like what that guy said i'm
offended and so they developed their
policy now not around the idea of free
speech but the reaction to speech that
offends people that is not free speech
free speech has to completely ignore not
even taken to the equation the reaction
of someone regardless of the speech
barring crimes someone's going to care
for you
and a crowded theater shut up i took
humanities 101 too what we're talking
about is actual speech regardless of how
offensive the issue is facebook twitter
google youtube but twitter's been the
worst they react and they create
algorithms that favor the reaction to
offense of speech
and they claim that they do so under the
guise of free speech
am i articulating that do you understand
what i'm saying yeah yeah absolutely and
it's basically the lowest common
denominator though he said we want to
have the largest possible kind of you
know group of people talking and so
we've got to remove essentially those
people who say something that's
offensive and i'm like well you're
you're polling the audience jack do you
understand that that will never stop
there will never not be a grievance
against a certain person or group and
you will actually limit the audience by
doing that and it's also not genuine
because do you know what offends me to
one side yeah that's the problem is he
favors one side it's blatantly obvious
right well you know what conservatives
right-wing don't tend to be offended
even you who's a moderate but you
believe in free speech and comedy yeah
my reaction is not to typically be
offended outside of the vaccine sketch
from stephen colbert that was
offensively very scary but i just don't
see how that's comedy yeah well that's
offensive it offends the sensibilities
yes
but i will say this it's not even just
propaganda that's worse form but do you
know what's offensive to a lot of people
i don't know to doctors biologists
saying hey biological women are the
exact same as men when the international
olympic committee now says you don't
even need to change your hormones at all
to compete with the women we're just
going to punt it to the individual
sports which they don't do with steroids
when they say hey
we need to sign legislation that allows
children to be put on puberty blockers
now people react not saying i'm offended
but hey this is wrong and those people
get banned those people get throttled
those people get removed the hunter
biden story which would alter the face
of an election gets removed and one
thing i want to make very clear here
this is also a problem
where we don't live in an entirely
capitalistic society
it's not just a profit motive you see
with the stock you see with the
performance of twitter he is acting this
way he is behaving as an activist
in spite of the business's best
interests you see that with hollywood
you see it with hollywood right now
continually pushing an agenda and now
you see pieces of entertainment
underperforming remember when george w
bush was president they had a series of
redacted rendition lines for lambs none
of them performed well it's not even a
profit motive which wouldn't make which
wouldn't make the destruction of our
basic rights namely
first amendment right to freedom of
speech which does apply in a digital
town square if you
if you uh you know have the the benefit
of the safe harbor laws yeah um
it goes further than that it's an
ideological motive in spite
of what should be a profit motive it
wouldn't be excusable if it was profit
driven but it's not
it hurts their business and they will do
it anyway to get rid of the voices they
don't like because there is a message
and an agenda that is more important to
jack dorsey than even the bottom line
and he's failed at both absolutely and
and that ted cruz moment there was where
i was just like all right guys it's put
up or shut up time this is the most
clear thing that was within what two
weeks of when donald trump's stuff had
been leaked and
nothing about it new york times post
that he was talking about right new york
post comes out with 100 laptop story it
goes absolutely viral on fire they take
it down come back later and say oh we
were wrong to take it down but they
wouldn't put it back up right they would
not reinstate the tweet because at the
time this is their logic at the time we
weren't wrong right we're wrong now but
at the time we weren't at the time we
weren't wrong what do you mean well we
didn't know that we were wrong or right
well why don't you just do some research
what are we retired what giuliani had it
and they're like oh we don't need that
oh everything else it was on this show
that he first publicly revealed the
laptop remember he's like well i i i
have hunter's laptop here and frankly i
don't want to show the images on here
because some of them are reprehensible
i'm like
that that's the laptop yeah yeah pick up
a geek squad it was so surprising even
we were like wait what oh seriously that
that that one yeah yeah this last top
two the thing is that's that's honestly
just it's very hard for me to piece
there's
so much [ __ ] stephen in this like the
asians were in my house and i was like
it's right here it's right here it's the
micro film of who killed kennedy they
were they were they don't want that they
walked past it and they uh were
rummaging through my chock full of nuts
jaws i don't know
so
chock full of nuts makes that wonderful
coffee you know what i'm saying
wonderful coffee is chock full of nuts
right stephen no i don't know oh okay
well i'm gonna go play more hair dye
so it's the dripping it's the dripping
it's uh it's lo but it's low drip it's
it's low drip hair dye
also on joe rogan's podcast in 2019
dorsey claimed that twitter does not ban
global leaders here you go
um
powerful figures or public figures might
be in violation of our terms of service
but
the tweet itself
is
of public interest yes there should be a
conversation around it
and
that is probably the thing that people
disagree with the most
um and where we have a lot of internal
debate but we also have some pretty hard
lines if we had a global leader
including the president of the united
states make a violent threat against a
private individual we would take action
we we always have to balance that with
like is this a is this something that
the public has
interest in and i i believe generally
the answer is yes it's not going to be
in every case but generally the answer
is yes because
we should see
how our leaders think and how they act
by the way erdogan is still on twitter i
believe the leaders of hamas are as well
and then he banned donald trump
president donald trump a year later even
though donald trump tweeted a video
requesting the january six protesters to
be peaceful yup just to be clear he was
speaking live said make your voice
patriotically peacefully heard and then
released a video where was reiterating
being peaceful this is something just
like when people say he claimed to
refine people on both sides referring to
nazis no no watch that clip where he
said i'm not referring to the neo-nazis
who should be condemned totally okay
not them horrible people condem i'm
saying you had both people on both sides
of the statue issue right who were very
fine people they misrepresented it and
they used it to ban
they lied to use i was being a little
live none of those lied to remove the
president of the united states and guess
what the stock value of twitter took a 5
billion dollar yeah nose dive after
they've been stunning though i mean how
do you get past all his charisma
so much silver devil yeah he's just
hard to not agree with when he's just
staring down like a complete
and
with birds in his beard and nipple
barbells in the middle of his tongue
no not me
that's not you
yeah we might even have to say for the
president if he said something oh that's
weird that's like foreshadowing isn't it
yes isn't it
strange yeah thanks steinbeck with your
literary techniques yeah it's really
good twitter immediately became less fun
when they banned donald trump yeah like
what what is the funny tweet this
morning hey are the chinese ambassadors
still on twitter who said that the
united states military created covet
probably so what about the what about
yeah
calling for the death of the jews yeah
yeah that's not a specific person it's
an entire race of people yeah exactly
and let's be honest who among us doesn't
get tired of them being a little too
jewish right and i mean and never in
history have the jews had to deal with
anything terrible no of course no i mean
it's their turn yeah they have nothing
bad to say or crying out loud there's
damn near 60 000.
oh hey by the way what's the name of
this new variant we're going to move so
i want to hear what you guys think about
jack dorsey we'll have more information
uh i think that they're probably asking
to step down because he's consistently
screwed up well i think some lawsuits
are coming in the state of texas in the
state of florida i think that it won't
be able to hold up boom and i think uh
what's this i keep forgetting the number
now section uh section uh oh the uh
220 220. section
of harbor laws
yeah i think those things might those
might go away yeah and i think that
they're very concerned and right now
they know that 2 30 2 30.
mundane i knew there was a two something
in it
so that matters 230 to 20.
what's the name of the new the
breakthrough variant now the new covet
decepticon
what is that orion uh no i'm not
electron and biden's actually going to
be speaking about that in 45 minutes
really well they'll be sure to wake them
up so you mean in four hours and 45
minutes yeah in four hours and 45
minutes where they like they literally
just have to get a forklift to lift his
day bed
into his clothes when they have to throw
out his ninth pair of khakis from
walking the stage
yeah he did it again we told you not to
wear dockers anymore uh we're dark
dungarees ah i didn't say tan i said
brown crying out loud we have a
president brown forgets where he is and
shits himself former vice president i'm
not a joke
there's a reason that this country might
break that's not holiday decorations i'm
sorry on cnn right now those are what
are those trees tell me what those trees
are i don't know i believe christmas
trees i believe that cnn is trying to
reflect the fact that we really only
celebrate christmas at this time of the
year not because we know that that's
when specifically christ was born but
most likely when the babylonians
celebrated with their solstice
that's probably it's just hard to fit in
a chiron gerald credit where it's due
you son of a [ __ ] nope no credit well
yeah
they're on kwanzaa decorations because
as we've discussed that's not a thing
people actually sell it doesn't exist
it's a terrorist organization who was
founded by a terrorist man who did time
in prison for beating and raping women
he would burn them with soldering irons
his name was ron everett screw you
kwanzaa's not real i don't respect
kwanzaa i don't respect anyone who acts
like kwanzaa is a real holiday you can
go screw yourself i hope i've
crystallized my thoughts for you when i
did kwanzaa i changed my mind on campus
remember those big fat angry black
lesbians they were like oh yeah how can
you say and i just say that i'm trying
to be descriptive so you can go back in
the video oh that's who he's talking
about big fat angry lesbian said hey hey
how do you get to say kwanzaa isn't real
oh do you celebrate kwanzaa
that's not the point oh oh isn't it no
one no celebrates kwanzaa it's i went to
ponza fest and i asked people do you
know if kwanzaa isn't like what's
kwanzaa you were the only one in african
garb yes
punch and pie yeah yeah stealing
everywhere nancy pelosi celebrates
i do yes yes yeah i have my garb she
gets your three twenty five dollar ice
cream scrub like representing the
different this represents the african
people and the
concept of liberation shut up shut up
shut up nancy pelosi how do you feel
about my ice cream is chocolate today
yes yes yes it's chocolate today is
there a bum dude
on my driveway shoot it
[Laughter]
okay so it's oh oh micron is the new
variant oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god um so this
is now there's a new variant
of the covid
who saw that coming well
so surprised wait is there something
they want to distract from right now is
there could there be anything
i'm not entirely sure i don't want to
attribute motive okay all right but i
want to get into look and i'm going to
say something that will maybe get me in
trouble but i'll tell you when i am
getting to the point of conjecture
or speculation
the na i'll i'll tease it the narrative
has been oh the vaccinated the
unvaccinated are putting the vaccinated
at risk
i think it's the exact opposite that's
all it's there and i'll get to it in a
second so the omicron
omegan omicron
or octagon octagon it's like a
transformer with no powers octagon
sponsored by guaranteed rape.com
enunciate sunday fauci gave an interview
uh that means yesterday claiming that
republican detractors
are criticizing and here's the thing he
said this two or three times before
and we have dr fauci actually on in a
couple of minutes we're going to i
should have said that we have him on the
show
which i credit where it's due yeah but
i'm amazed i want to ask him about this
i'm amazed that he said this before that
he was science
and it was met with very little fanfare
yeah and he continues to say it so here
he is this sunday making the same
unbelievably narcissistic
megalomaniac megalomaniacal fouchy-like
claim it seems another layer of danger
to play politics around matters of life
and death right exactly exactly and to
me that's
that's unbelievably bad
because all i want to do is save
people's lives i mean
anybody who's looking at this carefully
realizes that there's a distinct
anti-science
flavor to this
so if they get up and criticize science
nobody's going to know what they're
talking about
but if they get up and really aim their
bullets at tony fauci well people could
recognize there's a person there so it's
easy to criticize but they're really
criticizing science
because i represent science
i am a science wow
yep you don't aim bullets no one no no
one says no you don't you don't unless
you're neo no one says
to him at any point
hey
look
stop saying that you're the son
maybe don't do that like this is it's
not when i watch this i don't go okay he
said something stupid i go
no one is just no one cares about him
enough to say all right look tony we've
been friends for a long time right you
know let's go grab a beer and sit down
at the bar maybe ask how the family is
doing right i assume estranged and he
says uh okay look tony
you're doing a lot of good work here but
yeah
you've you've got you've got to stop
telling everyone that you are the
science
because it rubs people the wrong way and
it's also i mean you haven't practiced
science in 30 years
yes also wanting to be called king of
the jews is a bitter yeah yeah you know
lord of fouchy and we think that the the
custom crown of thorns that you had was
just distasteful i'm just saying you
know i tell you as a friend because i
care and i don't want you to embarrass
yourself
let's just stop with king of anything
and then you are the son tony i've also
i've seen the baseball card on your desk
did you see the pitch did you see where
you ended up ball yeah lady fingers i
wanted i wanted to tell you about this
before you actually called tops to
custom make the baseball card to put on
your desk
i just said i'm just saying as your
friend as your friend tony look as your
friend
you might come across some sometimes
your great have a lot of good qualities
okay tony but sometimes you might come
across
as too much of a piece of [ __ ]
that's the kind of conversation i would
hope someone would have with me
and he's like oh
i think you should focus on your major
league pitching because it's better than
your science right which is saying
something
so actually uh here to discuss this
right now mr the science himself
we have doctor do we have them on do we
have them on yeah we have dr tony fauci
oh wow
[Music]
okay dr tony fauci can you hear me sir
yeah
i am the science okay all right well i
get that that's you have to get that out
of the way so this whole thing has been
one of the most detrimental uh
experiments that society has has really
ever witnessed
you must not criticize the science
well i'm not i'm criticizing you when
we're criticizing i am the science right
we're criticizing your science we're not
criticizing actual science i
am the science okay well see saying
stuff like that is why ted cruz wants to
wants to prosecute you dr fauci for
being the science uh i am this i did
nothing wrong okay oh what what about
allegedly uh what about well not
allegedly what about lying about gain of
function research i
and the science okay that's always going
to uh you lie to i think i see a pattern
here a little bit you lied about masks
dr fauci i am the mask that keeps you
safe oh well that's different well
that's different i am the scientist well
no okay i thought okay i'll switch it up
a little bit right back to let's go
different you tortured beagles
the media has brutalized me
i am the torture beagle oh what and also
still desire okay i don't think we're i
don't think we're getting anywhere i
don't think this is going anywhere oh
could i make one last point doctor okay
one last point we'll see
i
am the zion all right that's enough
doctor ryan no no no
[Music]
wow he makes a good point what a jerk
i'm sorry for wasting your time huh
i will say this look i've said we don't
know
is such [ __ ] because doctors get
into trouble on twitter if if we're gone
on youtube follow us you know mug club
rumble just i just wanna i can't i have
to get to the american breakup thing but
this is something that is ridiculous
while we're talking about vaccines
doctors get banned if they actually
discuss scientific results at this point
and i don't just mean consensus
pre-scientific consensus before the
experiment played out the experiment has
played out i can't say that not having
lockdowns has had a beneficial effect
but you absolutely cannot say that
lockdowns themselves have had a
beneficial effect and we can irrefutably
say that lockdowns 100
had a negative effect economically it
had a negative effect societally
culturally specifically with children we
know that beyond any shadow of a doubt
okay now
in that same vein i cannot say
that the vaccines are not as effective
as they claimed they would be keep in
mind before people were getting
vaccinated they said you will get
vaccinated you will need two doses and
you will not be able to catch transmit
and you won't die from covid that's how
they sold the vaccines have i been wrong
am i incorrect about anything so far i
mean it well it's only because you're
playing back what they said okay that's
the problem i just want to be clear
because i don't want to strawman anyone
we were all under the impression that if
you got the vaccine you wouldn't get
covered right that's what they told you
that's like a vaccine has acted
historically okay yeah well i think it's
just it's good that they change the
definition of a vaccine yes i always
like that it's updating so i can say
this without being banned hopefully all
references available at
louderworthcrowder.com including the cd
can see
um
the vaccines have not worked
by their description when they told you
the vaccines would work i want to be
very clear about that
not saying that there's no beneficial
effect on that on serious illness and
death that that is a little more murky
i'll get into that but as far as
preventing transmission
preventing the next wave
no now before we get to that the new
fear-mongering that is going on of
course from the science himself is that
a scary new variant has emerged so you
need to go back into your uh huddle at
home in a world fatigued by waves of
covet 19 now renewed fear
in south africa scientists identifying a
troubling new variant of the virus that
is dominating infections here a variant
of syria's concern which is now driving
this
spike in numbers more than 30 mutations
say scientists in the spike protein
alone it's a worrying sign okay just
just so you see right now we're live on
cnn there is
what
it looks like it is it looks like the
giant who would catch the code of the
fraggle mommy
you know what i'm talking about the
giant someone broke that up from the
controller i fraggle mom uh talking
about how the very high risk that a
micron poses then i'll continue with my
segment let's see
yeah wh
we don't like the look stressful but i
trust these people we don't have enough
information about whether it's more
transmissible whether it's going to
cause more severe disease and critically
you just said poses very high risks so
one of the lower counters poses yes we
believe this variant poses very high
risk oh in what way well the ways we
don't know whether it's more
transmissible or more deadly so in what
way do you know shut up shut up i am the
science lover so dr margaret what would
you say you do here well you see i'm
confused you've been over a decade since
i've had a good lay
margaret you have a meeting with the
bob's
it's a spitting image
ah i love it so what does this mean how
do you even know it's a variant then of
course well no they've they've tested
that and found that out but what they
don't know they've been talking sure the
test work though for the last day and i
have two days like two stripes yeah this
this is more transmissible they think
they're worried did sanji gupta came on
cnn hold on a second right now look it
says again oh my variant poses very high
risk people you just heard her say we
don't know if it is more communicable or
if it's more deadly so let's see what
very high risk it poses uh
that information is telling us that it
seems to be competing very effectively
with data's delta in other words more
people are getting infected with it than
with delta in the same sort of place but
that's in small number small areas we
don't have enough information worldwide
to know
but we do see that indeed it is popping
up in places all around the world
in the meantime countries are reacting
nearly 50 countries are now restricting
travel from hey by the way can you bring
up remember when biden and kamala harris
said that donald trump was racist for
blocking travel down to china yeah he
said it's un-american and racist i'm
sure we can bring that up and now
they're doing the exact same thing yeah
i don't have a problem with locking down
travel from south africa by the way i
don't have a problem with that really at
that point it doesn't affect us so much
you know but
the problem is they're going to
as little information as they have now
is the exact information they had when
they started the lockdowns yeah but do
you know where it is already it's in
canada it's yeah it's already moved it's
in hong kong it's in austria it's in
several south africa like what what do
you think you're going through well then
we have to buy the cats out of the bags
well i thought this was a good
opportunity to bomb canada they have one
case i think we go in and take it over
oh yeah just carpet bombers yeah get rid
of them i mean there's certain places
you want to keep but not most of us
just hands yeah we don't need
professional black facers but how badly
does the rest of the world need
professional blackfacers we don't need
cannon anymore so scientists have dubbed
the new variant oh micron after the 15th
letter in the greek alphabet and uh i
found this out interesting they decided
to skip over the 14th letter z
why did they escape you will not name
virus after me because they s they bring
great dishonor it was the secretary
that's my name they went to him like can
we name this g you will not name virus
after me
you will name it after orion belt but
add
you had your time you failed
now time for great pan pacific race to
make uh make the world money our farm
take it so you know what this means get
all of your boosters
listen to the government or we'll all
die
i'm saying this
absolutely clearly that if ever there
was a reason for unvaccinated people to
get vaccinated and for those who have
been vaccinated when your time comes up
to go and get a booster shot because
every three months even though there may
be some diminution and we don't know
that in the protection against the
vaccine certainly to be vaccinated and
boosted is always better than not to be
so that's the first thing is it i've
just discovered something he's standing
honestly a backdrop he's a coach of
america
he he spends a lot of time in bath
houses and locker rooms that's true yeah
exactly working at penn state
so i uh here's the
show oh here's the tweet what was it we
are in the middle of a crisis with the
coronavirus we need to
lead the way with science not donald
trump's record of hysteria xenophobia
and fear-mongering this is where he was
talking about the travel and then kamala
harris specifically actually condemned
the ban on traveling well well the
original tweet was actually him just
smashing a keypad and then someone fixed
it right yes exactly
and they just polish that up a wild
guess that i like ice cream so this is
the issue
right now i realize what the science is
when they say meaning the the dogmatic
scientist the foul jesus i don't know i
will say this i don't know there are
some things that we know but i don't
know at all when fauci says i don't know
people say well he doesn't know but
let's do what he says yeah that's the
issue he says he doesn't know but then
gives a prescription that is followed to
the letter whereas a lot of other
scientists say well we don't know this
but we do know this and so
we know for example that the the virus
still transmits with people with a
vaccine it doesn't seem to be actually
lowering overall caseloads in many
places with high vaccination rates so
lockdowns and
a lot of these protocols that don't seem
to be effective so we know that
and then this is what we don't know
about this new variant whereas what you
when you have vouchers i don't know
anything about that or this or any of it
but this is what we're going to do
yeah it's like no they came in with the
sky it's falling oh my god there's a new
variant oh okay okay how severe is it
well we don't know is it going to kill
more people we really don't know is it
more transmissible we really don't know
has it had an impact on south africa yet
well not really yeah i i don't
understand well they're saying now
boosters right but vaccine and boosters
are synonymous because you're not really
backing out a booster that's true so i
understand they're saying everyone needs
to get vaccinated and boosted because
obviously places with the highest
vaccination rates
have the lowest case loads right of
course yeah oh yeah it should bear out
so let's look at that the uk 80 fully
vaccinated they've had a 291 percent
increase in cases since january
singapore 92 fully vaccinated they've
had a 347 percent increase in cases and
that's when you're eight years i don't
believe numbers that's what the case
though ireland
yes
ireland 91
of 18 and older fully vaccinated
482 percent increase in cases since
january gibraltar all that alcohol no
germ should live in that year
with a gibraltar which isn't a country
by itself and i'll get to vermont as a
state as well over a hundred percent of
adults fully vaccinated over a hundred
percent because many of them have
boosters the way they measure
they have a 224 percent increase since
january 2021 all references are
available at lateralcredit.com i want to
be clear some of these places have the
highest case loads ever
but that shouldn't be required to say
the vaccines don't have the intended
effect in reducing caseloads some of
them just have a multi-hundred percent
increase but it's not the highest week
ever ever ever in some of these places
it's at its highest point ever when a
majority of the population are
vaccinated let's be really clear about
that okay don't want to oversell it i
still think a 292 percent increase is
not a mundane detail michael okay let's
look at vermont 73 fully vaccinated the
highest in the united states a 531
percent increase in cases since january
2021. it currently has the fifth highest
infection rate in the country with 61
per 100 000. let's compare that to west
virginia lowest vaccination rate at 42
percent they've had a 228 increase since
january 2021. a 46 cases per 100 000.
the point is here it's gone up in some
places where they've been uh
unvaccinated but it's gone down in some
places where they haven't been
vaccinated overwhelmingly if you just go
right now to world of meter and you look
up cross-reference yourself countries
with the highest vaccination rates and
you have to exclude some places like uae
because it's really a tourism
destination or like cuba yes you don't
get accurate statistics but go through
the top 20
and tell me you do not see a direct
match
with the highest vaccination rates and
the highest case loads
now what i'm saying i can't say i'm not
saying that it's because of the vaccine
i'm not saying that but what i'm saying
is what we were promised with the
vaccine has not come to fruition if
people if you were to go to people right
all the people who are running around
flailing in supermarkets if if you don't
have a mask even though they're
vaccinated right and tell them before
they got the vaccine say look you need
to be vaccinated and there's still a ver
they're still about the same chance that
maybe you get coveted even if you're
vaccinated but you probably won't die
from it
that's likely lower
even though in some cases the majority
of hospital visits and deaths are
vaccinated again it just there doesn't
seem to be a correlation at all because
this is a unique virus and affects
people differently by the way death
rates would be going down think about it
why would death rates of course be
expected to go down
because it ran through same reason in
italy it ran through old people and the
amino compromise like a buzz saw so now
the people who are more likely to be
infected
are people who haven't been killed yet
so of course you can look at the median
age of people who get coveted now and
it's getting younger not because it
infects younger people at higher rates
but because there are fewer old people
around for it to kill well and if
everything worked the way it should and
the vaccine was going to protect us all
would you expect to have more deaths in
the year the vaccine came out or the
entire year that the vaccine didn't
exist right
we have more deaths in 2021 than we did
in 2020 from this virus yes
and we've had the vaccine
the whole year right
let that sink in yeah again i can't i
cannot and i would never say
that the vaccine causes more harm good i
would absolutely never say it all i'm
pointing to you is that yes we've had
more deaths
and
significant portion of those deaths are
from the vaccinated depending on the
state there are variables we have higher
case rates in places that are mostly
vaccinated things haven't gotten better
they've gotten worse statistically
they've gotten worse in the way that you
expected this to be eradicated from the
vaccine yeah okay
now let me be clear while we're talking
about the vaccine because this new
variant the world health organization
said that omicron
has omicron whatever i don't give a [ __ ]
that sounds like a color someone would
ask for on their wheel well and pit my
ride can you make that [ __ ] omicron oh
my god i like the sparkles
[Laughter]
what does that mean brakes two weeks
later
i hope you got subwoofers because that
battery is gonna die every time
okay so the who said that this has uh
this mutation
actually has a bunch it has a bunch of
mutations specifically on the spike
protein yeah which may suggest that the
vaccine could not work all that well
which we saw with the delta variant
vaccine worked against the first variant
didn't work very well against the delta
variant we presented you that data from
mayo clinic and after five months it
worked almo it was statistically
insignificant in any protective effect
against the delta variant so this is
from the world health organization
omicron is a highly divergent variant
with a high number of mutations
including 26 to 32 in the spike some of
which are concerning and may be
associated with immune escape potential
and higher transmissibility this is this
is conjecture this is speculation here
okay can i be clear about this
i'm not saying
that this is this is uh
uh uh uh uh uh true
i have a hunch
people have been trying to vilify the
unvaccinated
right they've been trying to say hey
it's this is a pandemic of the vaccine
but when you look at places that are
more highly vaccinated people you mean
like the higher the president yes people
like the president people have tried to
you know in new york you're not allowed
to go out you're not allowed to eat in
certain places like austria you're not
allowed to be in public transit um
but when you understand and there are a
lot of doctors who've said this when you
understand how viruses mutate they don't
typically not they're exceptions to the
rule they don't typically become more
deadly they typically become more
transmissible why because a virus wants
to find more hosts it wants to survive
it's the law of really all living
organisms right
reproduce survive that's that's no
different with a virus and so when you
have a vaccine that is effective against
the original variant and if this is
observable so this is not conjecture
worked
effectively against i think the alpha
variant is what it was called
didn't work at all against the delta
variant what do you think is that now
we're having variants here that may
again evade vaccines may again
be at least more evasive than the first
variant against vaccines you're talking
about a virus going up closed door can't
get in this way maybe if i change and go
through the window there are a lot of
doctors saying
similarly to the way that antibiotics we
all know sometimes if you overuse them
can create super resistant strains of
bacteria
maybe maybe the reason we're seeing such
high case loads
in places with the highest vaccination
rates and seeing such a significant
amount of deaths among people who are
vaccinated at this point maybe it's
because
we've created variants
rather than any kind of natural immunity
because you know what if you send a
letter right now to the cdc and ask how
many cases do they have of people who
achieved natural immunity who
recontracted the virus they won't give
you an answer and it's not data you can
actually find i've looked you cannot
find the data on people who have caught
covid multiple times
there is no central database that is
accurate not one that would be accurate
enough i would feel comfortable bringing
to you like i do the overall vaccination
rates and caseloads why
right now we're asking will this evade
the vaccine that's a part of it are we
how about we ask will this evade natural
immunity because it's two different
things
yeah absolutely and the whole danger and
we've known this in science forever the
whole danger with not killing a virus
but just making it to where you can live
with it is that the virus doesn't just
pack up and go home and oh okay i guess
i can't work here it just
changes by the way i love how they said
this this is this is very artful immune
escape potential in that
do you know what that means it will get
around the vaccine yeah that's what it
means it means that the first virus was
really dumb just trying to get in going
the same way and then the second uh
sorry the vaccine the variant and the
second now this variant is trying to go
in and his body's just saying hey why
don't you just uh go use the side door
oh yeah thanks thanks man yeah i love
that escape potential that's good
flowery language use the fire escape
okay and then it climbs into your rectum
wherever it enters i have nothing oh yes
what is this the stelter variant could
be
here's another biden uh tweet that's
more about africa trump further
diminishes the u.s the reigns
further diminish the u.s in the eyes of
the world by expanding his travel ban
this new african ban is designed to make
it harder for black and brown people to
immigrate to the united states really
disgrace and cannot let them
have you been in disgrace you've been in
a cab in the last 20 years i think
they're [ __ ] i'm not even being a
dick like they love it here there's
plenty of people by the way from africa
does he also know that there are a lot
of white south africans yeah uh yeah is
he aware of that i don't think he's have
you heard of charlize faron
less and less every day though
that's true go watch invictus she's
disappearing quicker than her his mind
okay so we don't have time we have a
whole segment on black santa let's do
that tomorrow tomorrow
one quick update too for the dorsey
story so he earlier today it was
announced that he was expected to resign
he posted
i resigned from twitter and his uh
his successor is a guy named parag
agarwal
we found a good tweet from him if
they're not gonna make a distinction
between muslims and extremists then why
should i distinguish between white
people and racist oh well [ __ ] leader
of twitter how about that how about here
look let me tell you exactly why can you
bring that tweet up again and read it
for me
let me dissect this live on the spot hey
do you guys want to if you guys want me
to dissect smash that like button do it
smash that like button right now because
i just got irritated i thought my blood
pressure probably would go up about 20
points because this is the kind of thing
not that he says it but that stupid
people will say hmm that's really insane
yeah
kind of like oprah's book club yeah
smart man where they act like there's
any value okay bring it back up all
right prague agraval if they're not
gonna make a distinction between muslims
and extremists then why should i
distinguish between white people and
racism okay very very let me be very
clear first off muslim is not a race of
people okay that's one
muslim is a group of people who follow a
specific religion islam white is a race
of people so this is the new ceo of
twitter
new ceo of twitter comparing white
people to muslims extremists to racists
okay
muslim not a race of people white race
of people muslims follow a religion that
religion has a very specific
political and practical pragmatic
prescription as to how you live your
life now those words coming directly
from muhammad
actually include calls to violence not
saying that all muslims practice it but
to deny that muhammad lived a life waged
war called for the deaths of christians
and jews and called his followers to war
he called them to peace sometimes but he
definitely called them to war in a very
real and physical and violent sense of
course the founder of the feast is going
to lead to many of his followers taking
his words to mean what he said
you cannot find an example of that under
the umbrella white people race and i
assume he's speaking about the united
states where anywhere it says hey go
kill black people wherever they may if
there is a black person behind the tree
the tree will say the black is behind me
the black is behind me these are verses
from the quran
and the uh the surah and the hadith
just to be clear big big difference so
you can say that extremists have
perverted islam
they would argue that they're following
the exact words from muhammad
whereas even christians christian
extremists cannot justify violence
through the words of jesus christ it's
not possible to do
but you're not even comparing christians
and muslims you're now saying i'm going
to accuse all white people of being
racist and that also by the way assumes
that racism is exclusive to white people
how about you say oh you can make this
exact same statement if you're going to
compare all muslims and extremists then
i'm going to compare all blacks and
racism you see how silly of a comparison
it is
and this guy thinks it's insightful so
what that tells me is this is someone
who has set out with a prefabricated
agenda that he is going to push on
people regardless of how completely
devoid of logic it is
i hope i hope i've parsed through that
comparison for you i
just don't want any yes men here
anything that i've said here that
needs to be highlighted needs to be
corrected nope no correct yes
you see a problem with that i'm sure you
have something there i see a problem
with we did separate muslims from
extremists that's another problem he's
assuming that we just say all muslims
are going to blow themselves up at a
mcdonald's and we're like right no no
what we're saying is that for every
other week for a terrorist attack to
happen around the world and for us to
have to cover it all the time we started
to see a pattern we started to see a
pattern of these people saying this is
what islam told me dying in jihad is the
only way
the only way to be guaranteed to go to
heaven yeah in that religion so when
that is the case the most sane thing to
do is to die in jihad yeah hey you know
what let me bring up one more thing too
since he compared islam versus white
people now the difference is you don't
really have governments for example like
the united states is not a white
person's government i mean i think you
know if you just look at one of those
hearings
and even the california state
legislature because they were busy
throwing eggs at larry elder while
wearing a gorilla mask so i'll just
compare uh non-muslim countries in
predominantly white areas as opposed to
islamic countries that actually adhere
to islamic law so when he said hey hey
i'll just compare all white people to
or i guess sort of
lob into the same category white people
and racist versus islam and extremism
okay let me ask you this
uh
is it wrong for me to say that every
single islamically run country in the
world is extremist to me
name one that isn't
anyone saudi arabia iraq iran syria
let's go turkey uae qatar
even in those places you have women who
can't drive
even in those places you have women who
are stoned for infidelity even in those
places women don't have the same rights
as men do even in those places
you have punishment for for people who
are apostates who leave the faith of
islam name me one islamic country where
you could do the kind of [ __ ] that you
and jack dorsey do on twitter unfettered
should it ever come to criticizing islam
one islamic country where that would be
okay now can you name me any
white country let's just use the united
states as an example where they would
treat you the same way
is there any state within the united
states where if a woman doesn't cover
her head
she could be beaten is there any state
in the united states where a woman is
not allowed to walk in front of men at a
sporting game i'm using the moderate
examples here i'm not just talking about
cutting heads off at a soccer game you
do realize right you go to uae you have
time
for the sporting event a woman has to
walk around the men
can't walk in front of them particularly
there's any royalty there is there
anything even close to the most moderate
human rights infractions that you see in
every single islamic country here in the
western world i'll wait because to me i
think that's extremist
let me go one better here
how many places in the world where islam
is practiced as a major religion will
you let us set up a christian court yes
within your sovereign territory yeah
that doesn't happen anywhere you know
where it happens the uk
several places in europe they tried to
do it here i think they try to do in
oklahoma they try to do it in michigan
try to do it in new york
that would never happen right
no i just it's one of those things where
people always take an extreme example i
am saying the moderate examples of when
muslims attain power and use islam as
the basis for law
it's not a place i would ever want to
live it's not a place i would ever even
be willing to visit i think it's extreme
enough
but hey this is what we so out with the
old jack dorsey in with the new fascist
[ __ ] wonderful
at least he doesn't have a big long
beard that we know of yet and we have no
idea yeah but i think they managed to
find someone worse yeah well well wow
look i want honestly i'm not kidding i
know this is going to sound weird i want
worse i want it to be so obvious that
this person is evil
that it becomes clear and nobody can
make any equivocations just because jack
dorsey had birds in his beard
who among us has not had a beard long
enough to house birds
it's fair i mean
i haven't but i've had a moustache i
just want us all to be able to move on
from now i don't even know we're already
going late and i have this other crap
together
i don't give a [ __ ] about that
i don't want to talk about it
i i i had so at thanksgiving someone who
had never heard of jesse smallett and i
was like you must consciously be avoided
yeah come on any information
say his name stephen i will not say his
name say his the kid from mighty ducks
before he got replaced by keenan
thompson
yeah totally
yeah pay by check even gordon bombay
couldn't help that little prick
nope for those of you who don't remember
mighty ducks he's a drunk gordon bombay
gets like his third dui and the judge
goes you're a drunk and capable of
self-control i sentence you to spending
time with children
and driving them to matches
i don't know i don't know all right
you'll hit
zamboni very drunk i have to do this i
have to do this segment right yeah i
think it's okay all right we're gonna go
late today i apolo look smash the like
button if you're happy that we go late i
ask that you help us by commenting below
because sometimes
this is true sometimes the youtube
algorithm
hurts us if we go long
they don't want it to be beyond an hour
sometimes and so you guys just help by
commenting below have talk about
whatever you want to get quarterback you
look and see if they're smashing that
button or not and you tell us we'll stop
right in the middle of this don't watch
it pull over
smash it like you know you black people
uh smash something uh you know that
black everyday well is that what you do
just aggressively
all right um this is something i want to
talk about for a while you know i said
this before anytime you see an american
flag pin yeah you go oh conservative
anytime you see an american flag you say
oh conservative
why be well do i need to explain why
look why did people say that judge
schroeder over there in kenosha was
clearly a trumpist when he was appointed
by a democrat to be clear because god
blessed the usa was his ringtone the
left tipped their hand and said
god bless the usa obviously a leftist
obviously a liberal progressive wouldn't
have that on their phone probably not
you'd probably have the russian national
anthem
[Music]
so it's on um i want to talk about this
there they have a lot of people on the
left and on the right talking about the
country splitting up yeah yes no and
i'll get into the polls as to why it
seems like it's increasingly a
possibility and i think that would be
better than an actual civil war because
those get violent and we would obviously
want to avoid violence of course yes
just break up right just break up it's
not you it's me
well it's you you're not for the kids
it's mostly you yeah so i i'm going to
make a case here as tired of my business
i'm going to make a case here as to why
uh conservatives of course get to remain
america and liberals should be a
a separate country but i'll start with
this here's why
i think that if we split up as 40 of
liberals want to um
the left
should be america light or new whatever
because uh
they hate the flag and they hate the
anthem for starters
a new push by the california naacp to
get rid of the national anthem
this song is wrong it should never been
there
and just like we didn't have it until
1931 it won't kill us if it goes away
history if you know your history you
know the full song of the national
anthem the third paragraph speaks to
slaves in america our blood being slain
and and piltered all over the floor
it's disrespectful and it does not speak
for black americans it's obvious black
lives matter utah posted a picture of
the flag with the caption when we black
americans see this flag we know the
person flying it is not safe to be
around and is a racist dumb i don't take
it back because some of us live in a
different america we really do
we don't have the same experience
founder of black lives matter no way
dad take i need a chuck e cheese later
you freak listen she lives in utah i was
gonna say i'm guessing that she's the
number one draft pick for black and utah
yeah well
um
between her and kamal so look i could
say hey who gets to remain america and
who has to change uh well we
conservatively stay america why because
you don't want to have the america you
want a different flag that's not the
american flag you hate the american flag
you hate the american anthem bye-bye
that's it you're done no more
conversation you have to go create a
whole new country we get to say america
yeah i think i could end the segment at
that yeah but yeah is it wilkistan can
they have like that name uh i i you know
what they can have they can go create a
country and then we take over them and
subjugate them you know like the
non-extremist muslims do conquest
we wait six months and then they're in
bread lines and we just walk into it
yeah exactly that's a good thing
the breadlines so this is some of those
interesting it comes from both sides
before i get to the clip let me uh read
you a poll here um
recent university virginia poll you have
41 percent of biden voters and 52
percent of trump voters
want the country to split wow so that's
getting pretty close to 50
yeah across the whole spectrum and i
expect that to only go up
um sarah silverman and ted cruz have put
these side by side have actually both
proposed solutions to this problem so
it's not just the right or the left here
so like why don't we just finally just
realize that this
these states aren't working and like
divide up into like two or three
countries
of like usa one and usa two
and they can be usa one like the
conservatives can be usa1 because they
love being number one and that it means
something to them and i'd love to have
that
be theirs they can be usa one will be
usa too
and we'll be allies listen if if the
democrats end the filibuster
if they fundamentally destroy the
country if they pack the supreme court
if they make dc a state if they
federalize the neighbors on that stage
massively expand voter fraud
there may come a point they fight to the
death
of this
and then
where it's hopeless
then i think we take nasa we take the
military we take the oil
it looks like the one girl has a fishing
rod
so i appreciate that sarah silverman
said we get to be usa number one oh
that's nice of her uh the allies part
a little bit no no no no no
i mean we'll pretend we'll pretend that
we don't hate you be the greatest coup
in military history yeah things were
frosty with the british for like 50
years so yeah we'll need them we'll lay
low for like six and a half months
and then just take new jersey
yeah nobody's bottoming
from guard towers
so this is something too that's
widespread in media to be clear new york
magazine they have this story here
divided we stand the country's
hopelessly split so why not make it
official and break it up american mind a
house dividing gq the united states so
reviles itself it might actually break
up okay so this is something um
and i want to point out why we get to be
america number one and it's not just
because the flag it's not just because
of the anthem
liberals genuinely and i mean at this
point in time hate everything about this
country you cannot be a progressive and
like the united states of america let
alone love the united states of america
they wish that america
was like another country now
conservatives are happy that the united
states is singularly unique you know
when they say we're the only country in
the world that doesn't have socialized
medicine conservatives go we're the only
country in the world that allows private
choice with medicine and i get the
government unfortunately has encroached
too much in medicine right now where
it's kind of a hybrid of the two don't
get me wrong
but my point here is
we're happy conservatives are patriotic
because they love the fact that the
united states is different from all of
the other countries largely who sort of
spread from actual colonialism right
under the english empire uh this is what
you had you had empires that spread
across the globe and for the first time
you have the united states who is the
world's greatest superpower
ever
that isn't spreading across the globe
like an empire think about you've got
guam kind of puerto rico and everywhere
else we just have military bases where
we ask for really nothing more than the
land in which to bury the dead who went
to go fight for those countries which i
frankly don't think we should be doing
in the first place it's an anti-evil
empire we
love that the united states is what it
is now let me make that argument let me
let me go through it point by point the
declaration of independence and the
constitution
and show you exactly why the left hates
green woods god bless the usa it's
really because of the fact that um
let's read these uh the declaration of
independence i know it's been a while
for those on the left we hold these
truths to be self-evident that all men
are created equal that they're endowed
by their creator capital c with certain
unalienable rights capital r that among
these are life liberty and pursuit of
happiness now that seems like something
that's not a big deal and to
conservatives i know this is remedial
for you but to a lot of people who maybe
haven't brushed up on this the
definition of unalienable is very
important that means impossible to take
away or give up what does that mean when
you're drafting up a declaration of
independence this means a birthright not
a civil right a birth a natural right
unalienable rights are based in natural
rights meaning they are birth rights you
are endowed with them by your creator
because you're a human being
it is not anything that the government
grants you and the entire purpose of
writing unalienable rights which means
impossible to take away or give up who
could possibly take away
your rights
the government right that's what we saw
those are the government that's the
government that we fled yeah to be clear
so we said no no no no the government
doesn't grant it's not like common law
the government doesn't grant rights the
government exists exclusively to
recognize and protect
rights that is that is to be clear
singularly unique
in the signing the creating of america
and we'll get to the constitution in
ways that
in ways that undergird it even further
so uh let's some critical examples here
covet covert response yeah i think shows
an inalienable right like what
not having something stuck into your
body
that's kind of a big one right
not having someone come in and be able
to shut down your business yeah not
being called a non-essential worker
right
critical race theory
are all people created equal
black liberation theology yes the idea
the idea let me simplify this because
people say critical race theory isn't a
thing the idea that white people need to
apologize
for privilege something that they've had
no control over is that viewing people
as equal
what about special
affirmative action
where you have quotas for people to get
into schools or into professional fields
where they are less qualified based
exclusively on their race you say it's
because you're trying to enforce equity
however if you try to enforce equity you
cannot treat all people as being created
equal you have to pick one
uh i mean we can go to the freedom
they'll say well we're free when the
left says uh the left says freedom right
they said where are the party you guys
you guys want to tell me what to do what
they really mean is they think that
conservatives want to tell them who they
can screw or that they're not allowed to
kill babies those are the only areas
that you can find where liberals are
actually on the side of freedom killing
babies all the way up until including
birth we've heard that on that's the
actual policy of the main democratic
party and they want to have sex with
whatever they well look first off i
don't care if you i don't care if you
have uh sex with 50 guys in a truck stop
i could not care less that was weeks ago
look baby
48 baby steps i don't care we don't care
just don't consider it the same kind of
a family as a mother a father and kids
that's it
that's all it is so what they really see
is as as freedom from the left is i
guess
abortion on demand sexual liberation
free college free health care free ebt
cards welfare states these are not
unalienable rights you are not born with
a right to free college you are born
with the right to defend your life as we
saw with cal rittenhouse
see the difference are you starting to
get the picture
yes
let's contrast this with the founders
vision uh john adams he said our
constitution was made only for moral and
religious people it is wholly inadequate
for the government of any other let's be
really clear about this when people say
the separation of church and state first
off grab a constitution find it
that quote is not a real thing what
you're talking about is the infringement
on the practicing of religion state in
church right state in church what you're
talking about is keeping the government
out of the church running business like
the church of england you can read all
kinds of letters from thomas jefferson
to the danbury baptist there were
letters saying no no we're not going to
enforce a denomination or religion on
anyone but
in their i believe in their first i
don't know if it was their first meeting
uh meeting in the chamber of the house
george washington walks across and leads
them in prayer i think actually uh if
i'm not mistaken franklin did as well
one time even though he was most seen as
a deist so that you can find plenty by
the way deist of the founding fathers
you would consider them a christian
fundamentalist these days these weren't
adidas dias who were practicing tantric
yogi
tantric yoga right jack dorsey no
they're not jack dorsey with no but they
probably had some birds in their wigs
and the guy had wooden teeth
i was from england come on what do you
want so syphilis head
and i know people's
people will say
it's freddie's new nightmare people will
say that uh i'm straw manning them here
well no i'm i'm not i'm saying they were
upset about a patriotic song i'm saying
that they uh don't they refer to
american uh conservative patriots as
white supremacists but let me just
let me let you listen to them for uh for
themselves what they say you have to
take my word for it just take a look
it's in this clip u.n ambassador linda
thomas greenwood
i've seen for myself how the original
sin of slavery weaved white supremacy
into our founding documents and
principles
oh yeah like all men are created equal
in record time making sure that slavery
was abolished and it's like washington
and jefferson freeing their slaves upon
their death look slavery was going on
across the globe and it's a horrible
evil let's be clear about it
but we were the ones who tried to
enshrine it into law that it would never
be tolerated long term and fought one of
the bloodiest battles in domestic
domestic history i mean domestically for
any country really to to to end it
some some credit
the lord said god is having to hear
about it every five minutes yeah jeez
come on here you have former vice
president joe biden disregarding the
constitution while we're talking about
this the constitution specifically on
the cdc's uh and this isn't just i'm not
saying
this is unconstitutional right former
vice president joe biden with the
eviction moratorium is saying it's
unconstitutional i'm going to do it
anyway we'll pass
constitutional
measure
with this administration
i can't tell you
i don't know
there are a few scholars who say it will
and others who say it's not likely to
but at a minimum
by the time it gets litigated it will
probably give some additional time
while we're getting that 25 billion
dollars out of weird
in fact behind in the rent and don't
have the money okay the guy can't even
bathe himself i can't i want to do this
with the constitution you can't do
anything
walk up eight
then do stairs push-ups now joe prove it
that's a tall order ah it's all the
stairs so let's go through that let's
do push-ups my wrists
there's ripping through his skin
[Laughter]
like uh like jeff jeff goldblum in the
fly yeah in the elbows
uh-huh same thing he has to have someone
spit on his food to dissolve it does
that count as two
i just sit like a baby burger let me do
girl push-ups his once he gets to his
knees his femurs go back out through his
ass cheeks
i'm changing
come on chew your food and feed the king
[Laughter]
is his former vice president hungry
sorry joe biden's going to be late for
his address
so
let me go through the bill of rights
here where we can be really clear what
what is the left what does the left like
about the united states that's a genuine
question comment below what do you think
the left likes about the united states
we've talked about abortion we've talked
about gay people screwing great what
else
let's go through the bill of rights and
i'll tell you they despise every last
one of them and i have receipts
first amendment freedom of speech of
course you know assembly press religion
big one there is speech 51 of democrats
favor criminalizing quote-unquote hate
speech we just saw that umbrella used by
uh jack dorsey yeah to get rid of the
president of course you remember the
masterpiece cake shop supreme court case
we're talking about a business having
the right to
practice their business as they see fit
and again this is designed to be modeled
after other european nations and they
constantly point this is something else
too when you hear people like bernie
sanders
and elizabeth warren say we're not
talking about communism we're not
talking about socialism we're pointing
to the scandinavian country let me ask
you this we've been to a lot of black
lives matter right quarter black yeah
and we've been a lot to a lot of these
black lives matter rallies antifa
rallies
fun time i've not seen one norwegian
[ __ ] flag
you would think i've seen a lot of
hammer and sickle flags yeah lots of
those i've seen mostly those
haven't seen sweden anywhere
is it me
that's strange anyone ever see a danish
flag
[Music]
in chaz i've seen a danish
they have those are the that's the
women's march
yeah know they had a wonderful spread
continental it's a vagina hat a flag yes
does that count no i just i'm sorry
sorry but never once they use it no look
let's be honest it's marxism it's
communism you just heard jack dorsey use
that to justify removing the sitting
president of the united states for
urging people to be peaceful and they
want to the left wants to model us after
other countries where you can be
arrested for saying the wrong thing our
good friend mike ward in canada just
finally won at a higher court on appeals
he was fined 50 something thousand
dollars for a joke we've had stories
here in the uk where people have been
put in jail for they
for uh for doing covers at a karaoke bar
of kung fu fighting and it offended
people okay you do not have free speech
anywhere outside of the united states of
america the left wants the united states
of america to be like these other
countries let's go to the second
amendment that one's pretty clear the
right to keep and bear arms what happens
after shootings let's just biden did
this your former vice president biden
right after the boulder colorado
shooting i think we have a clip i don't
need to wait another minute
let alone an hour
to take common sense steps
i'll save the lives in the future
actually after the legislative process
but whatever the house and senate to act
we can ban assault weapons and high
capacity magazines item and transfer
this country yeah yeah
put him in the trash his son was
watching that going through his revolver
in a kid's toy box oh i gotta go well at
least it was loaded with blanks yeah
leaves it on the doctor's office where
there's like the ball thing yeah the
ball is this from the set of rust yeah
so what does biden want he wants gun
buybacks red flag laws national registry
to ban effective by the way you saw cal
right now it's kind of an argument there
that uh an old uh old double-barreled
shotgun which you would illegally and
irresponsibly fire into the air on the
porch upon your former vice president's
advice might not be enough when you're
being chased by serial pedophiles just
just saying in other words i think we
just saw the clearest example of why the
government has no right to ban high
capacity magazines also and look at
australia we see how well the band went
there yes really a good idea to get rid
of all your weapons right by the way we
also need to get rid of ford escapes
that's true
well because it's their fault how many
ford
escapes if you can save one ford escape
victim
you can use it for anything who can
forget this of course he's running again
in texas oh jesus they do a works camp
what did he say when the when the veil
was lifted in a moment of i don't know i
assume
opiate-induced euphoria otherwise this
is the most ill-advised statement i've
ever heard when you're running for
anything in texas here's what he said
hell yes we're going to take your ar-15
your ak-47 you're not going to allow it
to be used against our fellow americans
anymore dumbass okay he really is the
worst i love how he includes texas
an ak-47 has the ability to be fully
automatic an ar-15 is not i mean maybe
you can well yeah of course they both
he's an idiot no i know i'm just a laser
rifle when's the last time you saw an
african country that's got ak-47s
running around the russian military that
was like yeah you have to pull the
trigger every time every single time you
see it it's fully automatic every time
you see an ar-15 in the united states
yeah almost without an example of it
being the other way it is one i don't
want to say that i don't want to say
that i have a semi-automatic ak-47
but the point is they exist
yeah i see that every time i shut my eye
i know but it's like it's pointless yeah
no it's written you just said he just
said hell yes i want to lose this
election yeah but he did wish granted
done you know you're running for we want
to take your rights away vote for me
yeah yeah yeah and that's what i said
well it can't be used against another
american um i don't know could maybe be
used against the government trying to
come and take them away yeah
no are you threatening violence i don't
know are you threatening violence
no i'm just gonna take your guns away
that's violence prick
no i'm gonna take him away no you're not
i say no well you have to
no
you have to or else or else what you're
gonna send in people with guns to take
my guns away so i will respond to your
violence with violence
makes sense
people want to say it's it's
unbelievable that kind of gasoline like
hey you're starting violence if you send
people with guns into my home to take
the guns away yeah
of course you're starting of course
you're being violent
i don't know why this isn't basic to
people and by and this is one of those
things the the incredible case that many
people know there are going to be
supreme court cases on the second
amendment uh coming up soon heller
versus dc the dissenting opinions i
believe it was for the dissenting
opinions in other words this was a case
that said individual citizens have the
right to own firearms the dissenting
opinions weren't a capacity ban
weren't well you can't have an ak or you
can have this gun but only revolvers the
dissenting opinions from the liberal
judges were private citizens have no
right to own firearms whatsoever i don't
care where you line up and what you
think common sense gun control is can we
all agree that that opinion is not
reconciliable with the constitution yeah
100 what about chinese throwing snares
well well that's just like that just
ninjas just pisses them off
i'm pretty good with them are you a bird
shot i played shinobi too
yep
i got a whole door at my house covered
in them
because i'm special there's so many
channels on youtube for people who like
by throwing that oh yeah and i used to i
was at a christian youth group and this
guy was trying to impress girls he's
like yeah he was multiple yeah that'll
that'll get him wet yeah yeah ah sorry
he claimed he worked security and uh i
was a kid i was maybe 12 at the time i
said uh yeah carry a gun and he looks at
me he looks at the girls he goes no i
don't believe in guns i uh carry african
throwing knives
and i said he was 17. i said at uh 12 i
said no you don't
no
no
then i walked away by the way why isn't
his brother punch me because apparently
i ruined his chances with a girl during
a looting he was stabbed by just a
regular old african knife
i'm not even gonna throw this one
yeah just run you through
no why is that better why is it morally
better that i didn't pull it again and
go bang and kill you but i i sunk a
knife six inches into your skull and
killed you like yeah ah well at least
that's a fair pretty much because it's
you know why you're okay with it because
it's pretty much impossible to do no i
know i'm just throwing knives and ninja
stars are useless watch there's going to
be one guy who's a good practice
ninjutsu no you don't no you don't talk
about it
chinese slippers who watch too much
ninja
turtles go ninja go okay so this is uh
another example where what else do
liberals hate so first amendment second
declaration of independence let's go to
the sixth amendment fair and speedy
trial this is where we're talking about
the uh the whole idea of people being
allowed the legal process well i think
we just saw this take place where now we
have trial by media judge schroeder
revealed that people had been filming
the written house jury of course they
could be political moderates
now said the appearances are asked
before
other than the jury is not in the room
and
it was reported to me that
by lieutenants airline that uh this
morning
lieutenant zerlin
that this morning uh at the pickup
there was someone there and was video
recording
the jury
which
the officers
approached the person and
required
him to him her i didn't even ask
to um
delete the video
and return the phone to him um i've
instructed if it happens again there to
take the phone
and bring it here so and if you continue
the clip you're here god bless the us
and the third time
i'm gonna take my belt off yes
do you see my entire chair reclines even
with the pistol hey and that clip by the
way
because we were planning this segment
before the written house uh trail one
yeah after that clip nbc had the jury
bus followed yeah by the way bastion of
conservatism over there at nbc
you're villainizing people that are
there to do a public service right
that's what drives me absolutely nuts
about it yeah you have to have a jury
there these people are there don't dox
them and get them hurt for showing up
and doing their uh their what their
appointments do
you remember the community trial like it
was like oh if they don't come back with
the right verdict we're going to burn
this mother down there
because we have that clip of that
soulless succubus
we
maxine
waters
for a guilty verdict
we are looking for a guilty verdict
we got to stay on the street uh and
we've got to get more active we've got
to get more confrontational we've got
[Music]
there's not enough adrenochrome in the
world to turn back that biological clock
oh no
the montgomery burns treatment isn't
going to let that thing sound extra you
could hook up podlings like blood bags
to her
for the rest of her life in an iv drip
if she was in the cocoon movie you'd be
like you still look gross yes yeah it
didn't work for you what happened my
grandma's climbing climbing trees and
[ __ ] and you just you're just oh she's
drowning at the bottom of the pool
wilford brimley got his feet back yeah
for crying out loud and you're just like
from the diabetes
old wife climb a lot of trees does she
she climbs one every once in a while um
not to mention
let's go play in the pool yeah marco
vaccine's not going to come back i gotta
come it doesn't work she must be immune
from the healing powers i just can't
swim
she gets in there with she gets in there
with floaties ah where's the egg where's
the egg
a few people who remember cocoon i
appreciate you still remaining with us
yes the high brow comedy here yes steve
guttenberg classic
classic is redundant next here's the
former vice i don't give a rat's ass
when the former vice president says he
can eat a dick so oh wow
uh let's go let me show you what he said
about the shaving case before the
verdict was even reached
i'm praying the verdict is the right
verdict which is i think it's
overwhelming in my view overwhelming ah
it's overwhelming everything's
overwhelming let me go really quickly
here let me just go through the rest of
this again my question to you is you can
comment below what is it if liber if we
separate what is it that liberals would
keep that is american
they hate the anthem they hate the flag
we've now gone through first amendment
free speech no second amendment of
course not i don't even need to explain
it to you but you're welcome i did and
now we went through the six a minute now
let's get to the tenth amendment for
people who aren't necessarily familiar
with is federalism states rights this is
basically about punting things that
aren't outlined expressly beforehand or
in these documents to the states
everyone here understands that
apparently people on the left don't even
i guess they don't teach it in harvard
law so
hr one would be a federal takeover of
the elections just to be clear yep
titan's new house america initiative
would federalize local zoning laws to be
clear about that we're going to do a
whole segment on this this is basically
something where they will in order to
create equity in the suburbs people
who've left downtown they will basically
put pro section 8 housing into the
middle
of any suburb they choose yeah
yours right now
an area where people have left they will
do that and say well we're going to do
so in the name of equity what else has
the left tried to federalize well of
course health care we know that that was
obama's big accomplishment that he
attempted abortion they want abortion to
be taxpayer-funded nationally on-demand
taxpayer-funded period education the
federal department of education a lot of
you don't know this but your parents
probably went to school and had higher
than average test scores and better uh
better quality of life after school
before there was a federal department of
education it was all done by the states
marriage they want there to be marriage
laws across the country as opposed to
being recognized on a state-by-state
basis if you look at what the left does
they want to federalize everything
centralize control centralize power
remove your individual rights so this is
what i say i say this but i i honestly
if there's a counter argument that i i'm
missing i really want to hear it from
you i really do i i can when people say
hey
liberals have changed now you say well
that's just a cop-out and i look back at
jfk
you're talking about a guy who reduced
taxes you're talking about a guy who was
actually more of a war hawk than a lot
of people when you look at jfk and you
look a lot of things that he did he
absolutely would be considered a radical
republican today
it has changed it it definitely has so
in other words i can hear that argument
and look at comedians yeah i mean
carl and lenny bruce i love when people
say what if carlin was around today it's
like no he stood against everything you
believe in yeah i don't know if he would
have morphed though because a lot of
these people
then they go like oh well now i want to
be more sensitive you know oh no he was
talking about not cardinal you've seen
his less special yeah he just seems like
a grumpy old man knows right wouldn't
you always kind of
you fought for all this and then it was
like oh fine you're all just terrible
he's like clearly it's not going to
change i just wonder if he would have
been able to realize that oh my war is
not with the evangelical right anymore
it's these people because you see it
with people like dave chappelle but dave
chappelle was never aggressively sort of
like anti-christian because he's a
practice yeah he's not either yeah but
george collins was always these silly
people on the right these evangelical
christians and i wonder if he would
realize oh the left has become more
dogmatic and is infringing sometimes
people are so they've dug their heels in
so much they can't accept that the left
is more dogmatic than it's true but he
he also did an entire bit let's for
example save the earth people oh yeah
yeah at the same time as he was he would
always go back and forth whether
i mean he was considered liberal but he
ripped liberals apart on every single
special he ever did was that the one
where he talked about how they only care
about the cute animals yes he said uh
like we hear all the time that dolphins
are getting caught in the tuna nets
what about the tuna getting caught in
the tuna
he's like you think of some plastic
bottles that's going to stop the earth
volcanoes it just names off every
natural disaster because it'll shake us
off like fleas yeah you're not helping
anybody and then we'll be put into a
helmet with a beagle uh we have to get
we've gone over time so let me just
leave you with i wouldn't i am curious
to hear anyone's argument as to well
actually the traditional left
libertarians can you can't even say
libertarians look you have the right is
trump maga traditional conservatives
evangelicals working class uh proud
immigrants who've taken their
naturalization oaths libertarians the
left is
woke and james carville that's really
all you have on the left at this point
so if someone has an argument as to why
it is that they have any stake or any
claim the united states of america i
will tell you this if we separate and it
looks like we're going to go that way
the reason that conservatives
deserve to remain the united states of
america because what we seek to conserve
is the united states of america that's
what makes us conservative here in the
united states the left doesn't believe
that all people are created equal they
don't believe in equality they believe
in equity they don't believe in the
first amendment the right to speak
freely they don't believe in the right
to assemble freely it depends on your
political motivation they don't believe
in the second amendment the god-given
right to protect yourself they don't
believe in the sixth amendment when
we're talking about the legal procedures
that we have in due process they don't
believe in the 10th amendment they seek
to federalize everything the name of
more efficiency and more what what is it
again equity all of this is done in the
name of equity because if you scare
people enough to believe that the system
is stacked against them and the system
is so big that the only thing which
could possibly fix it
is putting more money into the system
well then congratulations you are a
liberal and you know what you get to be
america number two or maybe you could
just call yourself the system country
we'll continue being the usa with the
same anthem the same flag youtube thank
you you can piss off
[Music]
you